bonjour pierre conesa merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
emmanuel macron va s'exprimer ce soir à
20h sur la situation en afghanistan
quel est l'objectif du président de la
république quant à cette prise de parole
je crois que il en a tracé les grandes
l'ailière ans quand il a parlé c'est à
dire que il a marqué sa différence avec
la ligne américaine c'est à dire
il a rappelé qu'en même que il avait
l'intention de continuer le dialogue
avec l'irak alors que l'on est en plein
retrait américain et pour le moment il
aura la même ligne avec la paix distance
c'est-à-dire
il il a dit d'ailleurs hier que des
négociations avaient commencé avec les
talibans sur des évidemment les
questions que l'évacuation la protection
des ressortissants et c'est donc je
pense qu'il va annoncer que les
modalités du dialogue doivent se
formaliser je pense que ça doit être
seul il ya aujourd'hui alors vous l'avez
dit un les dialogues ont commencé en
tout cas en afghanistan avec les
talibans autour d'une zone sécurisée un
pur pour que les français puissent
continuer en tout cas leur opération
humanitaire est ce que
le dialogue court moyen long terme est
possible avec les talibans
il est très difficile de répondre parce
qu'on a eu une espèce de phase
d'optimisme forêt qu en se disant qu'ils
avaient changé bon en fait on rien ne
permet de supposer que les talibans pour
lesquelles ce sont les religieux qui
doivent créer la loi qui doivent
structurer le pays etc puisse imaginer
autre chose que la charia la plus
stricte mans deuxième remarque si vous
voulez immédiatement le débat a glissé
sur la question du terrorisme mais je
pense que personne ne prend en compte le
fait que la codi ce temps n'est pas un
pays arabe et que on n'a jamais eu
depuis dix ans en france d'attentats
fait par des afghans bon donc il faut
faire attention à s'ils voulaient pas
mélanger tous les problèmes
la discussion avec les talibans va
probablement se fait se faire sur la
question de la reprise de l'aide
économique mais conditionnée par un
certain nombre d'avancées est-ce que ce
dialogue soit possible ou pas c'est très
difficile de le savoir la france et
plusieurs pays ont annoncé récemment
justement diallo nié avec avec les
talibans est ce que peut-être on peut
imaginer dans un avenir plus ou moins
proche ou pas du tout une reconnaissance
de certains pays par
l'afghan dirigée par les talibans de
l'afghanistan dirigée par les talibans
pardon
oui on peut l'imaginer parce que
effectivement la voie militaire qui
avait été adopté par les américains
après le 11 septembre mais quand même un
échec assez flagrant c'est d'ailleurs 20
ans de guerre imposée parce que on ne
voulait pas traiter la question des
responsables du 11-septembre
rappelez-vous concept avec un saoudien
sur 19 terroristes évoque un avenant au
les américains se servent des excuses de
ben laden réfugié en afghanistan pour
déclencher une opération militaire alors
que les havrais avaient proposé
d'extrader vers la neige bannalec vers
une un pays neutre bon mais ce que les
américains ont refusé puisqu'il fallait
si vous voulez la vengeance après en
septembre et donc le choix qui a été
fait ce choix militaires mais il s'avère
être un échec complet donc il est
possible que maintenant on prenne en
compte le fait que l'afghanistan est un
pays musulman que l'afghanistan est un
pays très zariel que l'afghanistan est
dirigé par des gens va qui sont encore
montré leur capacité leur force et donc
quelle autre solution que le dialogue et
est-ce qu'on va aller jusqu'à la
reconnaissance que je ne peux pas nier
et est ce que les talibans aujourd'hui
au moyen de te s'organiser pour diriger
l'afghanistan aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr qu'ils en ont les moyens la
question c'est qu'à l'afghanistan c'est
à dire qu'effectivement ce pays soit
misérable que les cas soient vides faut
pas oublier que l'ancien chef d'état est
parti avec 6 millions $ dans ses poches
quand même donc c'est un pays dans
lequel le comédien le bilan de
l'opération occidentale est dramatique
donc on a encouragé la corruption et les
talibans apparaissent si vous voulez
comme avec deux caractéristiques d'abord
ils vont enfin établir la paix c'était
déjà l'heure la premier triomphe c'est
voler leur d'or lors de leur premier
passage au pouvoir il avait réussi à
réduire les chefs de guerre à ghazir ya
donc ils sont inséparables et faiseur de
paix est évidemment probablement comme
des hommes de lutte contre la corruption
donc ils ont deux atouts en bac et qui
fait qu'ils peuvent diriger ce pays
maintenant la situation des événements
sera de toute façon normative merci
beaucoup pire que d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin sur rtl france rappelle que
vous êtes aux fonctionnaires et
spécialistes à des questions à
stratégiques internationales merci
beaucoup